you know I am boy you know I'm that
little titty kitty you feel me meanwhile
you know sometimes I think about just
covering my body and um and rare fur and
just kind of milling around on a couple
of um you know titties
you know them sternum Nuggets baby than
big dogs
so that's why I'm at today oh I want you
to know that today's episode is brought
to you by grey block pizza and great
blocks of beautiful pizza establishment
if you've wondered what it's like to
have something Italian inside of your
face inside of inside of your freaking
little flavor hole then that's great
then that can't that can be grey block
pizza they've got Italian choices for
you great block pizza 18:11 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach in Los
Angeles gray block pizza get that hitter
let's go
[Music]
get a little bit money get that
ever
[Music]
that is North Mississippi Allstars and
that's their new song drunk outdoors and
when you do that when you do actually do
that and you drink outdoors it's really
one thing that's really that really when
when I would drink outdoors in the past
that brought me a lot of joy was being
able to urinate immediately you know
inside if you're in if you're in a
domicile or you're in a homestead and
you have to urinate or you have to pee
out you have to usually find a special
area to pee special area to drop water
but if you're outdoors you can piss even
you know you can flow out wherever you
can piss out wherever and it's very
normal
animals will see you urinating outside
and they're not kind of you know you're
not whispering other animals you know oh
look at Gary's wiener you know or he you
know he he oh you know tiffany has a
real you know she has a real weak stream
doesn't she you know animals will not
communicate with they're not they're not
up to as much chicanery and as much um
they're not making fun of you as much
whereas indoors if you're indoors you
got a pee the dog follows you you know
to pair it if they have a parrot it's
like you know looking around in its cage
wondering where you went
but secretly knowing that you've kind of
snuck off to urinate and that's one
thing that I do enjoy about about if you
are gonna drink anything outdoors
kool-aid water milk milk doesn't make as
much urine because your body steals a
lot of it but um water soda pop what
else
carbonated water carrot juice
other juices those things can create you
know a full decent blast of urine so oh
good to be back in the studio I just
flew in I got on this knee cow Taiwan
hit her that somebody gave me a
beautiful young fella I can't remember
his name and it was him and a couple of
other raagh ones showed up over there
and um this was in Milwaukee
outside of that Pabst Theater and man it
was the sweetest gift you know and this
fellow said he grew up over there and he
got our one week on where and uh and I
just made me think of my dad growing up
and when he was a kid and what he was
doing and my dad said when he was young
that kids over there they had a lot of
poverty in poverty you know that's when
you you know you you don't have you
don't even have a wallet because there's
no point in it it's not a wallet
wouldn't even be anything it would just
be not it would just be just something
like a little sack kind of this like a
really kind of rectangle sack because
you would never have any money and they
um and he said ah and my dad said that
the other children sometime would have
to eat dirt because they had so much
poverty and their bellies would get big
and large and uh and I always thought
about that a lot you know cuz I would
eat dirt sometimes I never had a lot I
would have a limited amount because that
always was in the back of my head
thinking oh my belly could get real
large and and I didn't want to be that
kind of you know kind of fat and dirt
and have dirt in me so but uh thank you
for this beautiful shirt thank you it
was this past like nine days has been
crazy I mean you go you just started out
in Bethlehem Pennsylvania you go there
and there's just right when I got to the
casino the wind Creek
you know just a lot of wonderful people
in the lobby and getting to meet him and
that one couple had matching outfits and
they were you know when the fella was
just real nervous to meet me and he was
like kind of started tearing up and
stuff and so I just locked arms with him
you know I locked arms with his you know
his big beautiful ass and we just stood
there and just kind of held each other
and that [ __ ] was it was beautiful man
it was beautiful it definitely you know
I felt like just part of the Lord's
homework right there like something was
getting done and then what else man we
get we went there then we drove over to
I don't even know fill it up
I don't even know threw ramas we saw a
couple Amish and we didn't sneak up on
him anything we stayed chill looked at
him from far off you know i romanís was
out there with me and he had them
binoculars and so we'd uh you know we'd
drop scope on some Amish and just you
know watch them nice there were nice
people crossing the street is what
mostly we saw him do and uh that's it we
wanted to spend more time out there
that's how to Lancaster Pennsylvania
that's where the Amish are really
milling around and kind of that's where
you you know if you want to get a good
recipe or something mer that's where you
kind of sneak in there and you meet a
lady and you can know you know it's hard
to kiss him I think it's almost they
don't you got to almost sneak up and
kiss him real fast but and then where
else we went through Cleveland Wild I
was crazy
Cleveland was crazy we went out after
the show that show was crazy as a
tuesday night is almost 2000 people and
[Music]
and went to Indianapolis then we went to
Pittsburgh Oh Pittsburgh that's where he
went and we went went to the bat the
football game and the Stiller's boys
talked about people enjoying and you see
people out there they got a little bit
of chipped ham on them everybody's
talking about chipped ham over there by
the stadium oh you want some oh you need
some chipped ham on it and I thought
chipped ham I thought it was a guy at
first I'm like who where is he you know
chip town bring his ass out here dude I
want to meet this guy but it's a meatus
of meat choice and people were making it
and you saw ya people eating a lot of
people licking their fingers out there
of it in Pittsburgh Dave thank bang bang
bang bang that was probably the rowdiest
crowd of the week was Pittsburgh no it's
probably too rowdy a squad and where
else finished off in Milwaukee and
Madison which were two of the two my two
of the best shows really I thought of
the week Detroit was pretty wild
sorry just so much happen at once it was
just such a crazy you know we got this
tour bus this real small tour bus then
there was only about two hundred dollars
a day rental and Ira manna slept in he's
sleeping in there and you know he said
he wanted to honest he said he wanted to
touch women in there and I told him I'd
allow it you know during nighttime hours
and as long as it was consensual
because we don't you know we got enough
of the dark arts going on on on our own
side of the bed and and then I think I
gotta you know there was a moment in the
week where I was keyed up and excited
and then I started to like I kind of
forgot that I was you know that I just I
just kind of lost a little bit of not
focused but I just realized though I
have to really I was just having trouble
honestly just big finding gratitude and
being grateful and I don't know why man
it made me some may be mad you don't
want to be grateful and just feel the
joy of uh of just every moment of life
if I can you know I want to see people
you know you know see a couple of you
know you might see a couple little while
thick little fellas over there tickling
each other or something or sharing a
bowl or something or doing you know you
know you see some you know a couple at a
table and maybe it's their anniversary
and they you know divvying up a couple
raviolis and I want to be I want to I
want to you know enjoy all the moments
of life and so so yeah really kind of
after Indianapolis I kind of had a
moment of like regrouping and stuff and
and after Detroit and tried to really
just say you know just really focus on
trying to be grateful and just uh
because I want to feel the joys of the
world man I really want to feel them you
know I don't want to be and I think I
started to feel a little bit bad that I
was doing a little bit of masturbation
this week I don't know what happened but
something about you get into Ohio you
just start kind of jerking off I guess I
do
and I didn't expect it you know I watch
a Browns game or something or I'll see
uh you know I'll see um the the
Cavaliers on TV and I don't think about
touching myself or anything you know
being real unique with my dick or
anything but then I got into that state
and I just couldn't stop just just doing
it dude and I was just I thought I don't
know I just you know had a little bit of
a setback there and once I start doing
it then it's like this downward little
you know kind of spiral where I'm just
kind of pleasuring myself and not really
but just not feeling great about it so
anyway I mean it's the dark arts tour
and sometimes the dark arts really bite
you right in the freaking back of your
nuts you know where nothing's ever
supposed to put its teeth and I kind of
feel like a little bit of that's what
happened um so with that said man that's
you know I'm back I'm back and I'm just
so thankful that so many people came out
man it just uh you know it just really
just blew my mind man you know what
I think part of it is I just feel like I
can't do enough to like no matter what I
do it's not going to be enough to show
my gratitude you know it's like there's
no way I can I mean I try as I try hard
but it's like it's just tough it's like
how do I show my gratitude to all these
people at one time so I just want you to
know that thank you very much you know
and I care about the stories that I tell
and I care about the performance and and
I had a good time and I hope that I can
repay that favor to all of you guys for
coming out and supporting me and just
making me feel welcome and it's quick as
one city to the next it goes you know it
goes and we think of some highlights we
have re got stuck at the gas station in
pen somewhere Wisconsin and we left him
back there we didn't know and a friend
of mine was telling me that her husband
left her at a rest area one time for
seven hours she'd gotten out to urinate
or whatever and he thought she was
resting in the back of the camper and
took off and he left her there and she
did have any shoes on either so that's
pretty and it makes you wonder well what
kind of guy leaves his wife at a rest
area but then it doesn't make you wonder
that much because I could think of a
thousand guys I would do that you know
drop Susie off over there by the
freaking by the RA but then it also
makes you wonder what what kind of lady
gets out of the rest area barefoot where
millions of people are driving by
sheerly to stop and urinate on the side
of the road
so it definitely seems like those people
are at least they know that they are
right for each other I think that's an
easy one
oh I saw March nemesis in Detroit you
know my buddy but also you know
Christopher
[Music]
he was in Detroit man he was doing a
college over there and I got to go to
dinner afterwards with him when we met
up and Blake Griffin's the all-star he's
a basketball ER you know and he's very
diverse man he probably have nine
different ethnicities in him I mean if
you beat him open the Olympics are
inside of him you know and he's just
extremely diverse man Blake Griffin's
and he and he's tall so we have to
really get close to his food to eat it
so it's very unique watching somebody of
that stature you know come down to a
little French onion soup or something or
a little salad plate you know but so
even that was just a joy in its own
right you know I know I'm name-dropping
but just to watch a real tall person eat
you know you don't get to see a lot of
that and almost feels like a little bit
like here at the zoo when you get to see
a real real tall fella have to deal with
even a little dessert in Blake Griffin's
hands it looked like a little like a
magic snack or something or like a it
almost looked like a pill he would take
in the morning and and it was a muffin
like down so to watch a man of that
stature just very complex it's almost
beautiful to watch you almost hope want
there to be a sunrise in the background
or something or the Lion King playing or
something it's very very unique but that
was that was a that was a fun moment I
want to tell you this too that I got a
show at The Wiltern in Los Angeles
that's going to be December 10th at The
Wiltern in LA and those tickets are
going to go on sale
tomorrow Tuesday October 15th those
tickets will go on sale and that's
tomorrow at 10 a.m. Pacific Standard
Time with the code on word and tickets
go on sale to the general public disc
Friday October 18th at 10:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time and that show is
for December 10th at The Wiltern in Los
Angeles and there's no VIP for that show
just general tickets and it's gonna be
it's gonna be an awesome night hoping to
have a couple special guests pop onto
the lineup with me
so thank you guys for for supporting me
as well the oxen Hill the Maryland show
and the sayers Ville New Jersey shows
you'll get updates about those this week
locking in some dates right now you know
it's kind of sad to be doing so like
some of these shows is like the last
time that I'll do these jokes in on
stage you know it's kind of crazy it's
uh it's I don't know it's like almost
like heaven
you know you have these bits and you
won't you know you have these stories
and you uh I don't know I care about
them you know I like telling them you
know I'm grateful that you know I lived
enough of them and was able to put them
in a some type of place you know shape
that I could present them to someone and
have them be enjoyed you know a lot of
people come out and you see it you know
you see a mother they had a mother and
son that came out and this week and
and it just man it makes you feel good
you know when it sometimes even it's
like it's like it's been hard for me
this year to really feel a lot of stuff
I've just been so almost busy too busy
to feel and not like I want it to be
that way he's just you know it's just
been I don't know
just been a new experience it's been a
new experience of like being having this
much work to do and and uh and just
thank you guys for your patience while I
figured it out and just continue to
learn and uh I don't know man I don't
even know what I'm saying really but I
don't know and it just been it's been
kind of a scary time you know like a
lots changed this year and it's weird
because it's like I don't want it to
change like and maybe it hasn't maybe
I'm just feeling different on the inside
or feeling strange or something I don't
know you know it's definitely exciting
to have more of an audience but it's
also it's a little spooky you know it's
a little spooky because yeah I don't
know you just want to do you know you
just want to treat people right and uh
yeah
and so having people come out it's like
I almost wish that I could be the
concierge there or the you know the
usher right when they walk into the
theater I could be the person that
welcomes them at the door I could be the
person that sets them down I could be
the person that takes their order I
could be the person that like I want to
be all those people you know I think I
want to be able to
I want to be able to make sure that it's
a good experience for you so sometimes
let us feel all this and I know that
that's impossible so it's this crazy
like thing that my that my brain or that
my alcoholism makes up and just you know
I have one of those brains it'll always
kind of make me feel bad about stuff or
make me feel like I'm not doing
something you know I got that dirty
brain I mean if you if you looked in my
brain there's definitely there's a
couple sand bars in it it's probably a
clay bank I bet there's a bit of a
compost heap somewhere near the back
there's definitely some birds kind of
doing sex off to the side probably sex
birds you know a couple penis pigeons
over there catching it but so but yeah I
mean just do the touring happen so fast
it's like people are like oh did you get
to do this in the city dude I didn't get
to do anything you know I had two days
in Cleveland where like my biggest time
of peace and one of them I got to go to
CVS cuz I had to get some minoxidil to
keep my hair and the other one I did a
yoga class there as well so yeah you
just because you get to the place it's
used about three or four when you get
into the nut to the next city and uh and
the camper was cool one thing about the
camper you know you just kind of can
kick your feet up listen to some tunes
be alive have a water they got a little
refrigerator you could try to sleep but
if you sleep in the back of a camper
every bump you hit it lifts you in the
air about eight inches so it feels like
you're just like somebody's [ __ ] you
but it's just they're not it's just you
bouncing it almost feels like the whole
world is just [ __ ] you kind of from
the side you know or that's why I laid
face down because I'm not if I'm cuz
even after a while I felt like the whole
world is like kind of doing sex app at
my butt or towards my butt so I lay face
down so that you know if the world's
gonna [ __ ] me it's gonna straight up do
it at my face or do it at my front so I
can kind of defend myself against it cuz
you're just in the back of that camper
you know that's the beautiful thing
about this tour bus we had it has like
kind of a camper vibe to it and so you
go lay in the back but every bump you
hit in it I mean it was intense
yeah and uh what else I got some time to
chill I'm getting my hair I'm getting
rehire for a station tomorrow so a lot
of people like what do you mean bucko
and that's where they take care out of
the back and they put it in the front
someone get that remodel job again and
this man dr. kay Hanover in Los Angeles
dr. Kayne I'm gonna see him and and I'm
intrigued ah you know like I you know I
just want to be preventative you know I
want to be preventative I like having
hair I'm not ready to be away from my
hair for the rest of my life yet I think
I have like separation anxiety when it
comes to hair and stuff like that so
what else is going on I'll tell you this
right here you know it that uh you got
to tighten up your grooming area a lot
of people's crotch you see a man's
crotch or whatever it looks like it's a
you know an Orthodox Jewish person or
something or it looks like a hippie you
know it's got the long hair you'll see a
guy's wiener and it got long hair off
the side a sideburn off his nuts and
it's got some bar rats in it come on
bucko
what are you doing boy well support for
this past weekend comes from manscaped
who is number one in men's
below-the-belt grooming manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels that's right you want to
get them rubies looking classy I mean
you want to be able to show your nuts to
your damn stepmother and not have her
trip out just have her be like wow huh
if only you kept your room is clean
I've taken care of my nuts before when I
was young a man told me one time he
cornered me actually not even in a
corner he just cornered me out in the
open and that's a powerful man and he
said whenever you do trim your nuts you
pull the hair away and then you clip
don't try to clip right by that bag
because you don't want what's in there
that's what he told me and I remember
that and even though still I've cut my
nuts open a couple times on accident I
know that I shouldn't do it
well manscaped is changing the grooming
game with their perfect package 2.0
inside the perfect package you find the
electric trimmer called that lawn mower
now real shady is to take anything
called a lawn mower new you jump but
this thing is waterproof and it has skin
safe technology it'll protect you from
nicking that sack you know what I'm
saying it ain't Christmas yeah you don't
wanna be st. NIT you can also create
less mess by trimming in the shower now
that's kind of sexy too you could even
do a video have your son you know video
you and give it to your wife for
Christmas or early Thanksgiving gift a
little freaking turkey hide or present
also thus the crop preserver is an anti
chafing ball do door ana moisturizer
take care of your nuts dude
they're your nuts bruh you know I'm
saying your family came out of them and
you're gonna [ __ ] run around all day
smelling like gravy and freaking off you
know and cheap Musk a lot it's time to
get clean with this perfect package 2.0
get 20% off and free shipping with the
codes Theo at manscape calm always use
the right tools for the job
get 20% off in free shipping with code
Theo at manscaped com 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape com use code Theo
to carry a crotch and feel like a man
what if you could make your work take
less time well you can with kaptara
kaptara helps you find the right
software for your business needs fast so
you can get back to business even faster
compare thousands of software options
read reviews and instantly narrow to
your favorites you'll have more time in
no time
get the software hitter get the software
right now it's the leading free online
resource to help you find the best
software solution for your business if
you're not sure well how do I make this
happen faster in my business how do I
get my product created and get it served
and and get it shipped how do I um how
do I get these facts organized so I can
create the best piece of necessity for
my consumers you can do all that no
matter what kind of software you need
kaptara makes it easy to discover the
right solution fast visit kaptara c.a.p
ter are a.com slash theo for free today
to find the tools to make an informed
software decision for your business
kaptara
CA p te r ra dot-com / theo kaptara
dot-com / theo software selection
simplified what's what else is popping
with me man uh
just it's already the middle of October
you know when we stopped we were in
Wisconsin which what a beautiful state I
mean just we were you know we really
just winter you could feel winter you
could feel this cold little little man
with a dirty stick kind of poking us in
our butt and kind of you know jabbing at
our bee holes a bit in a a cold cold
little kind of cold wet little hitter
that little you know you know that uh
polka Potamus bra he was just jabbing at
our frickin little nard hole and um and
we stopped at a little pumpkin patch and
it was beautiful man had fresh animals
right there newborn calves fresh poop
they have fresh animal poop all over you
could step in a ship for free I was free
and then they had different pumpkins and
different
choices get you one get you little you
get a spoonful applesauce half a dime
half a dime for that little you know
that little fruit scoop hitter and
that's one thing that you got to love
that about Wisconsin only in select
States can you pull over on the side of
the road and have somebody scoop half of
a damn you know scoop of pureed uh you
know choice sweet produce into your
mouth for half a damn dime I mean and
that's one thing you gotta love about
American that's one thing I don't want
to lose about this country you know it's
one thing I do not want to lose about
this country is the ability to just stop
on the side of a road and find Joey and
they had all kind of pumpkins big
pumpkins small pumpkins they had the
pumpkin patch you know when they got the
big old when they got one off to the
side as a little frickin needle and it's
uh you know when it's some carriage
there's you know because everybody's
suffering some and and just the whole
they probably had about six thousand
pumpkins and about four hundred of them
were special needs it seemed like or had
you know emotional issues or something
very and it was interesting to see what
kids would pick a what pumpkin you know
some kid they wanted a nice-looking one
some kid would pick kind of a little
rescue pumpkin you know the one you know
it's kind of shaped a little maybe like
a s a little and it won't even stand
upright it just keeps falling on its
side you see a little girl go get that
one well you see you know some [ __ ]
kid would just go over and just kick a
couple pumpkins some complete [ __ ]
some little auntie [ __ ] it or whatever
this guy was or whatever you know a
little freaking vegetable Nazi or
something you know we just but it was
interesting to see and watch how two
different children got the different one
and what they chose
made me feel like ah I don't know it
just made me feel real human just
walking around looking at vegetables
with strangers
ah and just nice to just be out in the
countryside and just see I mean in LA
you don't see anything you know there's
no countryside there's no birds I mean I
don't even I don't know if I've seen a
bird here in almost maybe five or six
years you know except for the scooters
so my brains a little warped but a one
city that really blew my mind
Indianapolis beautiful city I didn't
realize it I just I'd never been you
know I'd only been to the airport and
droving over to UM Bloomington but it
was just you know we got some scooters
and we're scooting around and the police
some guy had gotten hit by a truck or
something he's laying on the ground and
so I pull up I'm kind of peeking at him
you know and just cuz I always wanted to
see a body and see if you see something
leave out of it you know I like at the
end of a moment you know when at the end
of life so this um and then some kid
some guys pull up and they say you know
gang gang bro we're going to your show
and they're like yelling at me I think
they've been drinking there were nice
guys but I and they're like idea and I'm
like uh and I'm the guys literally some
guys laying there just been hit by a
truck and this two police officers over
him and it was just so awkward I'm like
guys I can't yell over this guy if this
guy's dead
you know let's move up about ten feet
and discuss it so that was probably you
know that was pretty interactive one of
a nice experience
what else I'm trying to think that was
Oh after the showing Indianapolis it was
a gang a group of people outside of the
uh outside of the venue waiting to say
hello and that was really touching
because that was one show during the
week I was really having a tough time
and uh and you know I was just having a
tough time and uh and I got outside and
and there was a lot of people there just
waiting to say hey you know and uh just
good people a friend of mine passed away
actually on Tuesday night and I didn't
find out till Wednesday morning and uh
it's nobody you guys knows the guy who
struggled with addiction and
man it just really broke my heart this
week you know it just broke my heart
just stop
you know just do he was just a real real
loving guy and he was just trying really
hard to to kick the habit and to get you
know to get better and anything any any
and he lost he didn't you know and I
hope he's better now hope he feels
better now wherever he is it just it was
a you know it was just it was just sad
you know because like addiction is
something you it's an individual thing
but it's a it's a human condition that's
it's a sourness that's seeping into
people and um
man this guy the most charismatic person
that maybe I've ever met this fella and
he just couldn't feel how much people
loved him I don't think he could feel it
and
feel it now man wherever he is you know
this is a special dude so that so that
going into that day in that night ice we
stopped and got some bags a couple bags
of fluid and and just some tough just
you know some tougher runs but let's get
into some calls that came in you know
let me quit thinking about myself here
and let me think about you guys and see
what's going on in your world thanks for
being a part of this past weekend okay
love you guys take care of yourselves
huh hey Theo this is Greg from Indiana
so me my friends went out and caught
your show dude you did phenomenal I
actually just want to call and tell you
so I was at work the other day and I've
just been kind of in this like what at
work it's not a bad job but I just
really want to get out of it stop
catching up on some of your podcast and
you said something like resonated with
me you know you said nothing changes if
nothing changes I thought about it and I
went home and I applied for a job I'm
probably not qualified for but I got to
take a shot and the next day I get a
call from him at the interview it goes
well she says she's gonna set me up with
in-person interview never even had it
they email me a few days later and I got
the job so now I'm gonna be doing the
job that I think I will appreciate more
and enjoy more and I'll be making double
the money that I'm making now dang bro
that's awesome man that's really great
congratulations for trying something new
yeah it's crazy to sometimes think like
what can happen if we decide let I'm
gonna see what happens when I decide
that I am qualified
when I decide for myself dad I'm gonna
do something different
you know Jocko willing was in here last
week and one thing that's really been
pressing with me that we discussed is
staying motivated and I had been finding
myself more motivated even when I do not
feel like doing something to do it that
my brain doesn't dictate how my brain
does not get to choo-choo it my brain
can feel a certain way but it's not
going to choose how I behave all the
time I just can't let it do it anymore
I'm gonna have setbacks I know but if
I'm feeling bad that doesn't mean I'm
doing bad that doesn't mean I am bad
that doesn't mean that I can't still
take some action because yeah nothing
changes it nothing changes man
you know we'll sit around forever
wondering well what if I you know what
if I was a dog catcher would I be the
best what if I was a you know what if
I'd worked on that you know what I am a
valance you know search you know
searching for avalanches and predicting
them or of what is it called a geologist
who would I you know would I be able to
do it would I you don't know
and to say yeah I'm gonna you know what
I'm gonna take action nothing changes if
nothing changes man and I'm not
preaching at you I'm just uh I just want
to remind you because I you know I've
spent a lot of time in my life sitting
around wanting things to change and not
being able to make them change and not
thinking I could
and I wish somebody had told me that
earlier sometimes that in order for
something to change there needs to be
change I'm proud of you man I'm happy
for you but that's very exciting to hear
and that makes me feel good you know it
makes me feel good and thank you guys
for coming out in Indianapolis and I
needed to hear that somebody came out
and had a good time at that show because
that one in the Detroit one were the two
this week that I felt I don't know I
just felt a little disc
octoman
you
you know I think it just breaks my heart
sometimes that
you
that's something like as beautiful as
human beings are that we're dying
because of something as
you
has like dirty and preventable and and
sad as drugs and as addiction
you know it just breaks my heart just
breaks my damn heart bro it breaks my
heart and just makes me want to work
harder to be part of the solution in the
world you know it makes me it just makes
me want to take care of myself so that I
can just so I can be there for somebody
else if they need it not even know if I
can be but just so that there's a chance
that I can you know it just makes me sad
man but knowing that there's people out
there who are making changes and uh and
we're coming out and enjoying the show
that's exactly what I need to hear for
me and thank you for sharing that with
me brother you guys be good to
yourselves man gang brother it's here
the interior call I'll listen to the end
of it here too I just want to thank you
man you know you inspired me I know and
I'm making uncomfortable to hear
sometimes but you really did and you do
that's a lot of people keep doing your
thing alright you have a blessed day
ding dang bro you could tell any that
was one thing you could tell man a lot
of really nice people they're probably
the most just well-behaved children kind
of vibe out there oh here was one thing
that was funny in Detroit the guy right
up by the stage security he was
listening to music on his phone lie on
speaker
it was the most Detroit thing ever dude
it was like some rap music she was
hilarious bro alright let's take another
call that came in here the hotline as
always as nine eighty five six six four
nine five zero three and uh yeah no I'm
all over the place today it's been a
crazy year man there's been a crazy year
you know I think at the beginning of the
year I felt I knew so much more like
kind of felt like I was in my in my skin
and some days these days I feel like I'm
out of it but it's an exciting time we
got Halloween coming we got Thanksgiving
there's a great time to be loving this
is a great time to recreate a personal
relationship with the feelings that I
want to have more of in my life everyday
let's take this call here we go
dang you know what I feel is I there for
California I was just listening to a
podcast about you having a vision about
your cause and how you as they're just
hanging on everything yeah thanks for
calling as they I appreciate you calling
yeah my yeah it was so wild it's so
funny I was listening back to that part
of the episode and it was so wild that I
I was in Maui and I had a dream that my
father was in you know and I hadn't seen
him in so long
onward I just wanna let you know man
I lost my dad of five years ago six
years ago well my dad was murdered so I
try not damn and I'm sorry to hear that
brother I'm sorry to hear that
homework even keep track of it because
it still hurts but man when I'm feeling
down dude I get those same dreams is I'm
just chilling talking to him it's giving
me advice and the crazy thing about it
too is that we're talking is like real
life situations [ __ ] some [ __ ] I'm
dealing with you know and I got two boys
and
look after - so [ __ ] me being a father
learning everything I got to talk to my
dad sometimes and when I go to sleep now
I get to see him so all I want to say is
is in our alone people out here going
through the same thing
have a good one later gang bro thank you
for that call yet there's some
I wonder if there we were missing such a
big
element of existence that we don't
realize how much access we have to
people that have left before us you know
our parents or our children people we
care about anyone you know anybody
Frederick Douglas or damn Len Bias or
Mark Spitz or anybody Thomas Jefferson
it's funny it's like how much like how
close are we to the spirits and there
and we didn't even we don't even I don't
even know I mean electricity existed and
we didn't even know isn't that you know
and it's such a huge thing I wonder if
there's gonna be another
like oh there's this field right here
where they all are and how to access it
is like this and we we just didn't know
we were too busy out here working with
our hands on our outside instead of
working with our our spirit or something
or using the hands that are inside of us
whatever those are our feelings or
something to you know to access our
loved ones
because it's you know we we are you and
I are we are pieces of our father were
pieces of our parents we they are
technically still alive we are half of
them so yeah it would seem like the
bridge for them to communicate would be
decently strong and I just wonder if
we're if we just don't know of this
whole entire other electricity that's
around or that exists that's this field
where we can where we can communicate
with others who have gone before us and
those who are gonna come down the line
yeah but it was beautiful man when I
think back on it was cool to see my dad
just having just be in himself
yeah just being himself man and thank
you for sharing man and I'm sorry that
that happened your father you know I'm
really sorry I'm grateful you have a
couple of sons though that you can be a
father to and I bet it's really really
painful at times but I better sometimes
it's uh you have a special inspiration
that the rest of us can't experience
gang brother um let's take this call
that came in CEO Marty yo what's up
brothers Conner from Key West hey Conner
down there in Key West and Key West is a
real hotbed for um you know a lot of
homosexuality down there if you'd like
to meet a man or woman and you are one
of those and you want to meet the same
also a lot of uh they had a lot of
unique Birds down there and sunburned as
well
beautiful area beautiful let's hear more
thank you for calling Conner how's it
going I just got one question for you
Halloween's coming up and I was
wondering Amen brothers gonna go ask me
personally I was thinking about a like
maybe like a coked-up Cuban dude that's
kind of funny sometimes
might not be though or I was gonna go as
like my mom or something and freak her
out
Gang Gang oh that's an interesting
choice that's a really interesting
choice what am I gonna go as you know I
thought about going as a crab maybe a
land maybe land crab something not crab
meat but you know the the living animal
and I thought about cuz I don't want to
do like a wet crab because you have to
wet you know I don't want to be like
having to spray water on myself all
night or do anything like that so I
thought about a crab I thought about
being a rocket doing like a rocket I'll
outfit
[Music]
where I am right now I guess I haven't
really started to put too much thought
into it but I do want to uh I do want to
now that you brought it up to me you
know when this actually reminds me this
reminds me of a call that came in let's
let's we're gonna go to that now this
call came in was it last year or the
year before about a fellow and a
Halloween costume and I and and this is
and I ran into this guy actually in I
want to say it was Kansas City maybe but
this was about him and about his father
since we've been talking about fathers
and stuff let's uh let's go to that call
right now hey what's up Co is Brad from
Kansas hey I was listening to this past
weekend when we were talking about
Halloween and how you loved it Halloween
actually used to be my favorite holiday
men I loved uh being able to put on a
mask and just get away and everyone
seemed so happy but my dad actually
passed away on Halloween this will be
the second Halloween without them man
and I'm just trying to I'm trying to
understand how I just got back you know
how I get that love for Halloween back
because you know every time it comes
around I think about my old man and just
what are you doing and where you know
how he'd be proud of me man well I'm
sorry to hear that man about your father
you know it's it's a why it's a it's a
tricky deal I think being alive because
it's not gonna last forever you know and
I think you have a really unique
opportunity I see here you know your
father passed away there on Halloween
and what you could do is you could dress
up like your dad
you thought about that you know to
really you could be him and for one
night on the 10th you know for one night
of the year take him out and just you
know enjoy the world as if you're him
and I'm not saying go visit people and
surprise people or something like that
or stop by you know I wouldn't even tell
your mother or anything like that I
think this would just be something for
you and him to have together but if you
were to dress up like your father you
know you maybe could drive by some of
his old friends houses or you know maybe
dry or you know or go by the school that
he used to go to or something you know
take his spirit for a walk if you will
because I think there's something
special about Halloween you know it's a
time you know the way that that the
different chasms of existence and in in
in life and outer space and mother
nature and Pandora's Box you know in
God's bonnets and all of that the way
they all fit together it's very much
like a Rubik's cubes and a Rubik's cubes
is a shape that doesn't want to show you
who it really is and there's something
special on Halloween when all those when
everything kind of lines up and you can
walk through from the beyond to the
great beyond and to the before and you
can meander back and forth like you're
just in a big house party and time just
kind of shows up and just you know it
doesn't keep track of itself and a full
moon comes out and there's wolves and
it's a very very unique time and it's a
very much it's just a waterslide I've
just existence impossibility
it's like the universe just like loses
its memory for just a second and forgets
where it's going for just a second and
there's something special that can
happen on Halloween and so that's what I
think it would be very interesting if
you may be dressed up here as your
father and went out and about now if you
wanted to get real fun with you can stop
by you know maybe an ex-girlfriend in
his house or if he used to play cards
with his buddies you could set up a game
and meet all in him and do that you know
really live it out but I think that
would be a special way that you could
honor him man Wow and that's pretty
powerful right there you know that's
just and I'm not saying it because you
know I was talking about I just you know
it's just there's I mean it's just we
don't know if there's this other but if
there's just such a fine line between us
and and those who have gone before us
just like a mirror just a you know
they're just right there and we just we
don't have the map yet to access them
you know way and if we could just find a
way to I don't know I feel like we're
gonna start to develop a lot of new
senses you know the fact that we only
have five senses for such magnificent
creatures as humans seems very limited I
bet we could do more than five let's
take another call here and also let me
tell you that this past weekend is
brought to you by Skillshare if you
don't have any skills well change it
because it's time nothing changes if
nothing changes Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes and design
marketing you'll discover ways to be
creative curious get weird ooh what are
you doing I'm on Skillshare honey let's
let's get all of our panties off take
closes take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing even illustration oh yeah
draw it maybe draw it whether you're
looking to discover a new passion or
start that side hustle Skillshare is
there you want to learn graphic design
you've been saying you do for like years
and you haven't and you're not doing it
and you're just driving your truck and
it's wasting gas try graphic design
basics core principles for visual design
one of the most popular courses join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for our listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes go to Skillshare
comm slash Theo von again go to
Skillshare dot-com slash Theo von to
start your two months now that's skill
shared comm slash Theo von when it comes
to meat you want to get that that fancy
meat you want to get that decent meat
look I've had meat in my mouth that was
real suspect okay
especially over there in Pittsburgh do
down there about a stadium dude you know
I'm saying I've had a couple cuts of
chopped ham that fool man
I mean I don't even know who they came
off of quality meat matters even if you
see an animal in the field a cow animal
you say damned if they've got a tear
nice and stuff you say I'd like to have
a steak out of that out of that one
you see another one over off to the side
and he's you know he's barely you know
making it through half of a cream soda
or something that he's got taped to his
hoof you know and he I he he hasn't been
brushing his hair and he also didn't
finish school like guy that guy could
keep his meats not everyone even has
convenient access to high quality meat
so it doesn't matter what the meat is or
what it's doing sometime you don't have
access luckily there's butcher box
butcher box believes everyone deserves
that high-quality humanely sourced meat
I've got butcher box and let me tell you
this I'm meted up to the gills I got
some ones dang meat boy did I'll shake
your hand and leave a half a prime rib
in a non accident
no more trips to the grocery store to
get that meat meat you get better
affordable meaty selections every month
butcher box ships a curated selection of
high quality meat right to my home meet
me at the mall
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones of course it's free of
antibiotics what do you think the meat
has our the flu what do you think the
meats on doxycycline each box has nine
to eleven pounds of meat enough for 24
individual meaty meaty meals with
butcher box you get the highest quality
meat around just six dollars a meal with
Thanksgiving right around the corner now
is a perfect time to give butcher box a
try sign up today and get a free turkey
[Music]
plus $20 off your first box just go to
butcher box.com slash Theo or enter
promo code Theo
at checkout that's butcher box.com slash
Theo or enter promo code Theo at
checkout for a free turkey and $20 off
your first box get some mmm and they got
the meat man dude my freezer so meat it
out it's fun cuz I leave in the morning
throw some meat the thaw out get home be
like dang edible meat but that's what
I'm gonna be for Halloween man I think
maybe a wet crab or dry crab let's take
another call right here Oh Theo it's
exact called in yesterday telling you I
was on my way to go talk to my
girlfriend's father
oh yeah that was a Europe talk about you
were applying for that job man
I don't think kaptara could help you
find any solution to you had to ask that
manfred a' for the ladies a hoof and
marriage paul hand in marriage
onward taking her hand in marriage
this is my recap I felt like I should
call back and tell you how when he you
know it went really well it was
respectful the family they complimented
me a couple times which is really nice
everybody needs that every now and again
but yeah he basically said that I yeah
but I'm alright I've got it but I've got
a blessing so
I ended up driving Memphis and I end up
driving back to Nashville where my
brother lives my dad was there and all
of us kind of got a little bit made you
know after it
my dad was throwing them back my brother
it was just a good time
get fellowship to community boys so uh
anyways man appreciate you keep it up
okay gang brother get out there man
you're gonna make a woman a decent man
or these days who knows you might have
to wear a dress or whatever and your
wife might beat you but no matter what
you went about it the professional way
you asked the daddy ain't let me get
that trim for life and dad's a lot of
times sometimes they know it's the right
man sometimes I've had a woman's dad say
hey look get take this little [ __ ] off
my hands you know and I say well brother
did we I just met you man we're to
7-eleven right now dude you know so it's
you know it's a unique there should be a
website out there for dads just trying
to get rid of real salty little
daughters there's a little saltine
crackers you know there's a little
spoiled fruits but I'm glad that you got
one man and I hope that you uh you guys
find a little bit of love did I hope you
guys tickle each other until you just
bust all over each other
praise God brother thank you for calling
in and giving us that follow up as well
let's take another call here the hotline
is always nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three thank you guys for
being here on this welcome back episode
here gang hey what's going on here this
is Griffin from Charlotte North Carolina
thanks for calling Griffin and man
Charlotte is Charlotte is a beautiful
city in there that um that Carolina
Panthers team is doing well over there
with uh with mr. Allen they got a new
quarterback of it err mr. Keith Allen
doing it doing it throwing it long and
doing it and being wild and stuff and
looking sexy as [ __ ] boy sorry have us a
type-i dude looking like he's playing
well sorry homework original call
my girlfriend just recently broke up
with me
relationships three and a half years and
who I'm sorry to hear that man it's a
hitter gang it's been about four weeks
since she did it and you know I'm having
a real tough time dealing with it oh
this is hard to know that the reason
she's leaving is you know partially my
fault um I didn't put enough into the
relationship and she gave me a second
chance after second chance and and it's
just real hard knowing that the one
person that you want to be with doesn't
want to be with you anymore and I was
just wondering if you had any advice on
how to deal with it I saw him getting
choked up right now but it's hard to
talk about but um I just needed to know
if you had any advice on what I should
do you know I appreciate it man lovey
lovey lovey - man thanks for calling in
oh man that's such that's a that's a
tough one because you know you you know
especially if she says she's giving you
these second chances and she brought it
to your attention and you and you just
kind of kept with some of your you know
your behaviors I mean that some of the
truth is that you just you weren't ready
you know you can't be someone that you
just can't be right now you can't do
it's impossible you know you can't you
know this I mean here's the thing it
seemed like you weren't you were not
going to make any changes to make
yourself fit with her you weren't good
at you weren't gonna she is telling you
we're not gonna do that you know it
wasn't happening and that's okay it just
it wasn't happening so it sounds like
the only way that you guys would have a
chance to fit together well is if you
know you were different
so I bet there will be a time where you
will have another opportunity you know I
noticed that with love that's really
strong or love that that there's some
real basis to a lot of times you get
that another opportunity you know that
person sees you deeper than you can see
yourself and so at that time you may be
a person that can take on a relationship
and take on taking on well and show this
woman the respect that she deserves as
much as you probably don't want to hear
it man it's probably for the best right
now if you're not able to be the man you
want to be for her that you're not or
with her because then you would just be
continuing to solidify the idea that she
already has that you're not the man so
now you get a chance to step away and is
painful bro dude I smoked a bunch of the
damn freaking Newports I was blowing
Newports bro laying on the porch swing
and that [ __ ] thing broke one night
and I had a damn glass of milk I thought
I was doing ahh you know one percent of
Newports and stuff this one I was really
you know lift and heavy and doing
steroids and stuff but I was doing one
percent in new ports and the swing broke
and I broke that glass that milk glass
dude and a little shard of it came right
up in between the the boards on them or
the young the little pallets on the
swing and nipped me right in the ass boy
I mean I'm just my ass bled brother my
ass could bleed I remember that my ass
could really really believe when I was
younger
but uh
but I think you'll have another
opportunity
and you know it's hard sometimes when
people that we care about or that we
kind of put us in our place a little you
know change is kind of scary change is
scary you know but I think it can be
good this is just this the toughest part
of you're going through right now you
know that separation and all the
comfortable you know you had things
really the way you wanted them they were
comfortable and you know and now you
know it's funny when we don't treat
someone right and then they're gone
you know it's funny that's when you
realize how much you miss them you know
how much you cared and sometimes some of
us are the type of people that we had
somebody has to leave us for us to know
you
what I'm sorry that this happened man I
know it's probably not fun to deal with
but just keep just stay just keep
putting one foot in front of the other
you know everything will be okay take
care of yourself don't be alone too much
and and this person loved you you know
this person cared about you so that's
you're obviously someone that can be
cared about you're someone that people
want to care about and I think you'll
have another chance with this person I
think you just got to let it play out
yeah I wouldn't put too much pressure
right now
I think but life is long man and the
story has many terms
you
so let's see if you guys y'all might pop
up in a sentence again
y'all might have a new new paragraph
right around the corner
but whatever is around the corner it
needs to be new because whatever you
were doing now is not working if you
guys have just hitch back up now you
give me the same old dough so so let
this be a you know let this it's gonna
hurt but feel some of those feelings
feel what it feels like feel what's
making you think
you know uh and be brave in it be brave
in it bro be brave in it you know this
is your vietnam brother let's take one
more call the hotline is always nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three you know we're all just people
just trying our best and i'm happy to be
part of this group thank you guys for
supporting me
it's appeal so i recently moved my
boyfriend into this house with my
parents okay
risky move homework better live together
but my parents helped me move him in and
there was a giant hole in the bedroom
floor this house is like all kinds of
[ __ ] up it holds editor where and this
hole was particularly large and
particularly deep and while my dad was
trying to fix the hole he texted and
said I found out that this hole is where
the pattern is used to [ __ ] and piss so
now that I'm gonna move in the house in
a couple years and I'm going to sleep in
there in the [ __ ] Pope room always
people used to [ __ ] and piss there's
that never going to forget that one
pretty [ __ ] disgusting but I just
thought you should know that I need to
give you some advice on how to [ __ ]
forget about that so thank you for all
you do um Jane getting well I mean it's
almost goes full circle because I was
saying that one of the beauties of being
outdoors is probably to be able to you
know exonerate yourself of urine and
feces
wherever you want be natural out there
and just flow hole right on the yard or
whatever um I mean what's going on what
do you guys I mean who's [ __ ] in
their room what are you guys doing over
there that's the first thing I would ask
and what is your boyfriend have to do it
you guys move this guy in it kind of
seems it seems you know I think people
have [ __ ] everywhere if you had a map or
whatever or if they had ghosts or
whatever from bowel movements in
people's urine they'd be everywhere
you know a lot of people think that a
lot of dude I'll tell you this story
when I was a kid dude I took a little
Duty out of my diaper or out of my pants
probably I was thinking was about seven
put it into my sister's pants bro
so you know it's uh you just got to do
your best really you got to do your best
and and yep [ __ ] put some carpet down
or something
Jesus dude animals have been [ __ ]
everywhere dude a bear could eat you and
do and do to you somewhere about us
interstate and you'd be a little duty so
it's um sorry this whole story's got me
I don't know what to do but I think yet
it's pay attention you know like I just
don't even know where to take this at
where but that's what I'm saying dude
urinate outdoors
what lazy bastard it is just cutting a
hole into the floor of the room and
doing poops in it that's I mean that is
lazy so hopefully you guys had a good
deal on the house
one more call here nine eighty five six
six four nine five zero three thank you
guys for being a part of my life today
and uh and thanks for not giving up on
me on this tour when I went back out and
I plan on them doing the film doing the
movie and then change the mind and I was
just you know just excited to get to
bring this show a few more places and we
get to go to Europe and a few more
reschedules here in the States and then
it's going to be I don't know it's gonna
be a little bit bittersweet homework hey
what's up DOP to the is though this is
Brendan from Wichita you know that
widget it
what's up Wichita yeah like it over
there as Barry Sanders country a Barry
Sanders Park over there and that's where
he used to uh play football as a youth
homeward yeah you know need some help
you know my dad text me
this weekend I'm having a child and he
said to him and his wife who is not my
mother don't feel comfortable coming to
the baby shower because the last year at
a beer festival my dad may or may not
have tried to have
with my girl's best friend who's putting
on the baby shower so you know I told
just be an adult get over it bro but you
know just want to know you're a vibe
from what I should what should I do
thanks brother take care I think you
should invite him again if he says he
can't make it then let that be his
choice tell him you still love him and
that your honor you understand it's
gonna be tough maybe a little but now if
he does decide to come then you guys
should do a game where he has to like
where somebody has to reveal a secret
about somebody else in the room or
something kind of crazy or you know like
seven seconds in heaven or whatever it
is called or or do something you know
put sugar in each other's mouths or
something so that way they have to
interact I think that that would be fun
and pretty deviant but that should be
fun damn you dad's a GI out there huh
trying to holler at your ladies chat
your ladies friend
dang a savage brother but love can get
us man you never know love comes in all
shapes and sizes
you know but but yeah he should he
should not I I don't know what he should
do he did what he did so yeah you could
tell him a dude man up if you're gonna
hit on her at least come over here and
hit on the [ __ ] zygote that's inside
of my wife's body for an hour and a half
because that kid needs some love as well
so if you're willing to hit on a
shaundra or whatever over there at the
picnic then come over here and lit and
hit on this freaking big seed I got
growing but damn dude that family sounds
awesome
I'll say that cut man you gotta have
some fun you got to have some fun in the
family when people have been having sex
since the beginning of time you know
those drawings on cave walls of people
[ __ ] so you know you know they were
you know but alright man we did it man
we made it to the end of today to the
end of this episode you know a lot of
feelings out there a lot of people going
through stuff this is a time of year
when there is so when there's a lot of
spirits in the air when the leaves are
changing when we're changing when
there's opportune
you just shift and we have to know you
know he's just something real that I'm
grasping onto is this just a ghost
what's going on
but I think one thing I'm gonna try to
do is just just stay excited about it
whatever it is if the choices I'm making
if I don't know if they're great or I
don't know if they're correct at least
if I stay excited and hopeful then even
if I'm going down a wrong path man I'll
be excited while I'm headed down it and
you throw enough joy on a wrong path man
and it just might turn into a it just
might turn into a damn staircase you
know it just might take you to a might
take you to the place where you were you
were exactly where you need to be you
know my turn in Nuala
into a direction of good so I'm gonna
try to stay excited it's a good time of
year to be excited
you know it's a good time of year to be
forgiving it's a good time of year
you know there's things in the air
there's other elements you know the
spirits are waiting right behind these
moments next to us
and we don't have all the pass codes and
stuff yet but they're there they're
right there and that's uh that's pretty
cool you guys be good to yourselves you
deserve it and let's get leid out today
with a little bit gun alabama
[Music]
she was louder than the blacktop broke
down out of truck stop she looked about
as wild as the stove is she
[Music]
says she was a question saving souls in
Savannah and the lore the same in her
Alabama
[Music]
[Applause]